[Música]
hola
quiero empezar con una pregunta
cuáles son las habilidades más
importantes para desarrollarte en el
mercado laboral hoy se le preguntaron
es la capacidad de liderazgo de la que
tanto se escribe se habla
es tener un buen balance de la vida
personal y la vida laboral
este en el olfato para armar buenos
equipos de trabajo
y ser empático extrovertido para tejer
buenas relaciones con los clientes o con
los colegas
bueno no es ninguno de esos
las habilidades más importantes para el
futuro del trabajo en general no se
mencionan no se hablan mucho sobre ellas
no aparecen en ningún currículum no se
piden en ningún aviso laboral
y sin embargo constituyen un capital
humano valioso
muy importante dentro de una
organización hoy
y no solamente hoy sino de cara al
futuro más próximo
aunque no nos demos cuenta vivimos en un
estado de aprendizaje permanente un
concepto llamado kaisen de mejora
constante en los últimos 20 años
piénsenlo aprendimos primero a usar las
computadoras después aprendimos a usar
los celulares y en ese proceso una
multiplicidad de acciones humanas
cotidianas cambiaron de manera radical
esto puede sonar muy obvio hoy pero
tomemos unos unos segundos para pensar
en eso cambió la forma en la que sacamos
fotos cambió la forma en la que miramos
películas cambió la forma en la que
compramos cambió la forma en la que nos
pedimos un taxi cambió la forma en la
que conocemos al eibar una cita
todo cambio a la luz de la revolución
humana más grande desde la revolución
industrial
y como si vamos hasta acá
fue posible porque nosotros como
individuos como consumidores pudimos ser
ágiles en adaptarnos a estas nuevas
tecnologías
con más o con menor grado de ruido o con
más o menos resistencia
y en ese sentido
es interesante cuando se piensa que
el proceso de adaptarse fue lo que hizo
posible que esas tecnologías triunfarán
como lo han hecho no hoy
sin embargo esto no siempre es tan
evidente
y no siempre ese proceso es tan sencillo
vamos a hacer un ejercicio
levanten la mano aquellos y aquellas que
usaron un rollo fotográfico en el último
año
alguien
jejeje
bien y ahora levanten la mano aquellos y
aquellas que usaron instagram en las
últimas 24 horas
me imaginé
déjenme contarles una historia acerca de
lo que acabamos de ver
en 2012 kodak se fue a la quiebra
ese mismo año facebook compró instagram
que hoy tiene mil millones de usuarios
por día
y que le ayudó a ganar a facebook 16.6
billones de dólares solamente el año
pasado esto es 16 seguido de nueve ceros
para tener una medida
cómo se unen estas historias
kodak tuvo antes que cualquiera de sus
competidores la patente para la primera
cámara digital fotográfica
pero decidió no salir al mercado con esa
innovación para no poner en jaque el que
era su principal negocio en ese momento
los rollos fotográficos
kodak que aprendió de la manera más dura
el mantra darwinista de que el que
prevalece no es el más fuerte sino el
que se adapta con mayor rapidez
por supuesto que con el diario del lunes
todo parece muy fácil
en 2006 encontré mi profesión de una
manera aleatoria pero también es un buen
ejemplo de lo que pasa cuando un
individuo está dispuesto a reaprender y
a re transformarse en esa época yo
trabajaba en una agencia de relaciones
públicas multinacional y con mis
compañeros teníamos una cartelera de
corcho en la que colgamos chistes fotos
y también hacíamos chistes sobre los
clientes
parece entonces hacía un par de años yo
había descubierto los blogs
soy periodista de profesión y tener un
blog en ese momento para mí era como el
sueño de la piba porque podía escribir
lo que quería cuando quería sin que
nadie me bajara una línea y en algún
momento esos dos mundos se cruzaron en
mi cabeza de forma aleatoria y dije está
cartelera es una tragedia a punto de
ocurrir un día va a venir un cliente se
va a ver en esa cartelera no le va a
gustar y vamos a estar todos en un
problema entonces les dije a mis
compañeros
hagamos un blog privado sigamos haciendo
chistes pero fuera de la esfera de lo
público ya mis compañeros la verdad que
les encantó la idea pero había un
problema el 99 99 por ciento de ellos
nunca había usado un blog entonces yo no
solamente creé el blog sino que les
enseño a utilizarlo y no solamente a mis
compañeros sino también a mis jefes que
por supuesto participaban de los chistes
de oficina
alucinada con lo que había pasado el que
era entonces el director general de la
agencia digo segura me propuso
y desarrollar el departamento de
comunicación digital que en buenos aires
no existía y que estaba despegando con
mucha fuerza en otras partes del mundo
y yo en ese momento sabía usar los blogs
sabía usar facebook twitter apenas
empezaba le dije que si di un gran salto
de fe porque sabía que no sabía todo lo
necesario y también sabía que mi tarea
no iba a ser solamente desarrollar el
departamento de comunicación digital
sino sobre todo de aprender todo lo que
sabía sobre comunicación bajo la luz de
estas tecnologías que habían venido a
cambiarlo todo como luego sucedió
en este punto cualquiera de ustedes
puede estar pensando que lo hago sonar
muy fácil y que las organizaciones
abrazan el cambio felices y somos
nosotros los que nos resistimos la
resistencia al cambio es humana está
estudiada pero es una de las cosas que
más fuertemente necesitamos cambiar si
queremos mantenernos flexibles
por eso
en ese sentido me parece interesante
cuando pensamos en que a veces las
organizaciones que se resisten al cambio
tienen dentro suyo a los agentes del
cambio pero todavía no lo saben
y esto tiene un nombre escucharon hablar
del síndrome de casandra
en la mitología griega apolo le concedió
a casandra el don de ver el futuro
ella lo traicionó y apoyo no se quedó en
el molde
y lo que hizo fue no sacarle el don de
la adivinación
pero la crucificó y lo que hizo fue que
nadie creyera nunca sus pronósticos la
condenó a eso
el síndrome de casandra en el área
laboral tiene que ver con esas personas
que llevan ideas disruptivas nuevas que
podrían cambiar la forma en la que una
organización hace sus negocios pero que
se encuentran contra las paredes de la
inflexibilidad o de la incapacidad de
las organizaciones y sobre todo de sus
líderes de ver el valor de esos procesos
de cambio
steven 6 son es un gran ejemplo del
síndrome de casandra a los 25 años en
steven seis son trabajado en kodak
armó una reunión con su jefe para
mostrarle un prototipo en el que había
estado trabajando fue a la reunión
cargaba un prototipo que era más grande
que una tostadora eléctrica y que era el
prototipo de la primera cámara
fotográfica digital 1975 yo no había
nacido todavía
en la reunión steven muy apasionadamente
le cuenta a su jefe su descubrimiento lo
que había estado trabajando y mientras
steven hablaba los ojos de su jefe se
abrían cada vez más grandes
cuando steven termina su presentación el
jefe lo mini le dice steven esta cámara
no vamos a rollos
paso siguiente a steven le dan otro
proyecto y le dicen que por favor no le
cuente a nadie sobre su nuevo prototipo
y así es como la primera cámara digital
de la historia pasó a acumular polvo en
una estantería en kodak el resto es
historia
a los y a las casandras del mundo a los
que están sentados acá a las que están
sentadas acá les digo
esas resistencias tarde o temprano se
van a quebrar esa idea muy común de no
acá las cosas se hicieron siempre así
tienen los días contados el cambio como
la vida se abre camino
yo los quiero invitar
a que se sumen a un propósito que yo me
puse hace unos años
qué es ser agente de cambio abrazar la
transformación ser parte de esa
transformación sin resistencias ser
flexibles porque en un entorno laboral
incierto y cambiante la capacidad
de reaprender y la capacidad de
adaptarte son claves para mantenerte
relevante y competitivo competitivo
el futuro llegó hace rato
y no podemos darnos el lujo de quedar
obsoletos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]